Unfortunately, don't worry. We can
excuse you.
>> You do not commit evil.
>> And Allah will question you, not evil.
Evil.
>> So the brother is saying that we don't
speak about the connection with Allah.
But what I've said from the beginning of
my speech is
>> now you come back here, you will be
arrested. Understood?
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
£500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Asalama
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Muy man was giving a talk in Sheffield
in a masid and he was shouted at,
heckled uh verbally attacked uh by a
brother. We don't know who this brother
is. There's some speculations of his
mental health being not well and the
masid being aware of this. He was
escorted by the police, by the security,
by some brothers, etc. Um I have the
full footage of how that actually
occurred. Um uh it's a footage from the
masid and this shows you what actually
transpired and it gives us a bit of an
insight of why are some brothers
behaving like this like what's what's
the reason cuz I want to see what was it
cuz there's some speculations going
around that apparently mu made a joke he
couldn't handle or something along those
lines. Let's watch it for ourselves.
Here is the first footage inshallah um
of the occurrence of the brother being
escorted. But let's then go to the video
of what actually really occurred and
then we can go to somebody who actually
vouches for this brother who done this
and he deems to be misguided. Okay, why
is he misguided? Let's find out. So
here's a first video.
>> You do not permit evil and Allah will
question you up for evil.
So the brother is saying that we don't
speak about the connection of Allah. But
what I've said from the beginning of my
speech is
>> now you come back here you will be
arrested. Understood.
>> Okay. So that's the video. But let's
this is what actually happened. But
let's go to the full context of what
actually happened and what is the
brother accusing Muy M of? Um here is
the footage the camera angle on the the
the what he's reminding and let's see
how things transpired.
>> If someone does something I I'll think
about it. Sometimes you respond and
sometimes you don't respond. It depends
what it is and who is doing it. But
nonetheless the I have to bear. I have
to be patient for the sake of Allah.
Allah says
[Music]
Someone does an evil, you can do back to
them what they did to you. But whoever
makes amends and whoever decides to
actually come together, make amends,
Allah says you forgive and made amends,
your reward is with Allah.
>> Isn't that interesting? Uh I'm going to
let the video play in a minute. But
isn't that interesting that what he
recited, you know, Allah says it is
sinful in the eyes of Allah that you say
something that you you you don't do. He
just said something how he should
conduct himself patience and if someone
it's very interesting and look what
transpired and let's see did Muslim men
actually live up to that or was it just
a calam that he was saying let's see if
he actually lived up to that principle
and patience and you could have you know
attacked the same way etc. Let's see
better for you.
Whoever decides to bear patience and
forgive that is something
that you are supposed to be doing that
is more rewarding.
May Allah grant us a good reward.
>> So build a connection with Allah. Bear
patience. Understand. Go out and help
others who are struggling in a similar
way. You have a problem. Go and help
people with other problems. you will
notice your problem becomes small.
>> Why do you not for
>> Okay, so from what I can hear, he's
saying, "Why do you not forgive people?"
I think that's what I heard him say. Why
do you not forgive people?
Okay.
>> Why do you not address the two elephants
in the room or more elephants in the
room making Allah and you're sitting
here?
>> Hold on a second. He's saying there's
two elephants in the room. Making dua
other than Allah is all right. I'm
trying to understand what's is there
something M said otherwise in this talk
outside his talk let's carry on
so the brother is the brother has
mentioned an interesting point he is
saying we should be speaking about
calling out to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that's exactly what we are doing that is
exactly what we are doing we are
speaking about calling out building a
connection with Allah building a
connection with the masid of Allah
>> well this is interesting because number
one firstly mu man acknowledges is what
he said. He doesn't dismiss what he said
and said ah you know brother sit down
I'm talking and firstly you need to get
the ethics and ad which is lacking. So
you can see number one like look if
argument sake you're shouting at someone
if muft man was somebody who said
something atrocious or like whatever it
may be like then you can get up if he's
come and said yeah you know we should
hold hands with the you know with the
Zionist and this that he didn't say
nothing like that or argument say I'm
saying I would lose my cool and be like
you know how could you dare say that
there's nothing like that anywhere like
let's go worship an idol there's nothing
like that number one it shows lack of
and adab and it just shows How young
people this is a common trend you see no
manners no manners think they know it
all and what is he attacking I'm trying
to understand look I know multi is not
perfect I'm not perfect okay there's
things people criticize m of myself etc
we're not perfect but I'm trying to
understand what on what basis are you
attacking there's two elephants in the
room we should not worship
other than Allah okay agreed when did
said otherwise on what basis are you
shouting in a masid in a talk what kind
of business what kind of Let's just
carry on. Don't worry. The brother is
the he's okay. Don't worry.
>> Okay. So, you can see that he's even at
the beginning he told there was some
people going to go up to him and said
look leave like let him express himself.
He's addressing acknowledging what he
said. He's saying it's correct. We've
talked about that connection with Allah
subhanaa tala and you can see very
clearly you know he's from what I can
see he's dealing with this in a in a
immature way.
So, so basically what has happened is
unfortunately unfortunately don't worry
we can excuse him it's okay it it
happens
you
so the brother is saying that we don't
speak about the connection with Allah
but what I've said from the beginning of
my speech is connection with Allah
didn't we say connecting to the house of
Allah connecting with Allah making a dua
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sometimes
times it happens. I can explain why it
happens. We are all frustrated. Why are
we frustrated? We are frustrated because
there is a lot happening on earth.
>> Okay, you can clearly see okay, Muhammad
dealt with that in a very very well
manner. Um, and he should be that's
expected of him. We don't expect
anything less. So, you can see but now
there's this video of another individual
that knows this person that knows this
person and let's see what he had to say
cuz I was trying to understand some
context into this inshallah.
>> The same brother that people are
slandering in those comments. Wallah is
one of the most loveliest, humblest
practicing brothers I know. He's an
absolute asset to the community. Now,
I'm not here to refute anyone, but it's
absolutely shameless the way the mosque
treated this brother. He is known to the
masid. He's known to the community and
they treated him like he's some sort of
criminal. And you also have Muy men
commenting in this video saying that the
brother has problems or issues. wall
this is one of the most practicing and
cleanhearted brothers. I mean yeah
actually we I mean there's no thing
about him we have no doubt about his
clean heart intention but there is some
things that the masid by the way masid
called the police didn't ask him to call
the police you know m didn't ask him to
be escorted even told them stop like
leave him let him talk um so nobody's
nobody said that but the m said that the
brother has some kind of psychological
issues from what been told so of course
you know there should be nobody should
stand back etc this should not be done
this is absolutely wrong but let's carry
on
>> we should all feel this passion to
protect our religion from any individual
regardless of the followers.
>> Okay, that's fine. So, what are you
protecting your religion from? This is
very important. You're talking about
protecting your religion. Okay. What is
Muy Mang saying pertaining to the
religion that we need to protect it
from? Please, I'm I'm really intrigued.
>> Just Google Muy Mink and you'll see his
misguidance all over the internet.
>> Interesting. So, go and Google Mu and
then you see his misguidance. Wai is
man. Wai is so weird. What's his
misguidance, bro? What's his
misguidance? And this it's become a
trend with young ignoramises,
bro. Absolute ignorant. What what does
he say? Does he say go worship graves?
Do bida? What do you do? Go to the
graves. Worship the graves. What was it?
What's he saying, bro? Like I don't
understand, bro. This a mentality, weird
mentality of a individual that might
might have an opinion and because you're
a jahil, I'm not talking about this
person. I'm not talking about anyone
specifically. individuals come and they
deem just because something looks
abnormal to you, just because it's a
difference of opinion because you don't
like that he's misguided on what is he
misguided for? Well, I find it so
strange, man.
>> And to share a quick story of my own
personal experience with Muiming, I
asked him a simple question. Are credit
cards? He told me, "If you want one,
take one. If you don't want one, don't
take one."
>> Okay, that's your word against his.
Let's suppose he said that, brother. Do
you know how many people spies? I'm not
saying you're one. Spies, enemies of
Islam. Yes. Who are looking for our
downfall? Us. Us with fake stories. Man,
left, right, center, from woman accusing
us of God knows what to people trying to
catch us out. Brother, people ask
questions. I'll give a generic answer.
Yeah. Okay. What does he mean by credit
card? What's the definition of credit
card? Yes. Okay. So, it's it's like
that's your word against him. So, he's
misguided because you went and asked him
a question and he gave a generic answer.
Okay. For which we don't know. That's
your word against his. So he's misguided
because and that's his personal story.
You can't make this rubbish up, man.
Wallah, you can't make this up. It's
like you're looking for the downfall of
other people. How can I catch him out?
How can What did he say? Yeah, I went
once and like you know some people do
this. You know some sisters. Yeah, I
went and he spoke to me in this way or
he looked at me like that.
You don't see the good the brother does.
You don't see it. Nobody's perfect, man.
If you're looking for perfection, go to
Jenna, man. Go to the angels. Nobody's
perfect. Yes, we all have criticism that
we can give to ourel and others can give
those 100% man. I'm number one in the
front. But to now he's a misguided this
brother coming shouting in the middle of
Yes. So I just want to say brother and
sisters alhamdulillah as you can see
youngblooded people no knowledge
thinking they know what is right or
wrong talking about brother what does
mean to you? You think tohed is like a
robot but you don't even understand the
essence bro these people who talk about
I have personal experience with people
I've learned from talking to me about
has zero talk to me about risk comes
from Allah has no trust in it that is
shaking when he realizes somebody else
is going to take his position at work
brother man didn't you teach me riskaw
in Allah where's the gone you know what
it isam yes
you know this nice word buted in his
life. What is above good and good
manners ished? Yes. You know, you
probably be thinking what what's he on
about? How does manners mean? You have
no idea man. Go and study religion. Do
you think is just repeating Allah is
one? Do you think that is one? Yes. Some
of the mush said, "Yeah, yeah, we
believe in Allah. Is that
pro?" That's what I'm going to say. I'm
not going to blab on too much. I just
find it ridiculous, man. Allah people
looking for other people's downfall.
heckling a speaker given in a masid
where's your adab even if you don't like
the per speaker have respect for the
house of Allah have respect for your
fellow people Muslims that are listening
to there anyways brothers and sisters
till next time asalam alalaykum